do you remember when I did this question
here I pointed out that there's actually
this whatever to the zero term it's
hanging on the end but we do not write
it because it doesn't have an effect on
the ads on yeah but it is there now the
same way on both of these questions here
there's actually a whole bunch of
numbers I haven't written because they
do not affect the answer here are the
numbers I'm missing can you see how
these powers climb down from 5 4 3 2 1
etc
well that's with this guy that's
attached to this guy this guy also gets
raised by powers though instead of these
powers decreasing his powers increase so
in fact there's a 1 to the 0 hiding out
here and then there's our 1 to the 1 and
a 1 squared and a 1 cubed you can see
why I didn't write these because they do
not American affect the outcome however
when you get to this one it does so
let's do this one step by step together
what am I gonna write firstly and this
time I am gonna do it all the way
through because it's pretty
straightforward the coefficients are
going to need are 1 4 6 4 1 yes to have
them in your head the way work is I'm
gonna do the binomial coefficient even
when it doesn't affect the number and
then I'm going to work out what happens
with each of these and how many of each
of them I have so let's do it this way
I'm gonna have how many three ones on
the first term I'm just gonna have for
them right it just comes from there so
if there are four of them that means
accordingly there will be zero of them
okay I'll keep going you'll see how the
patent goes Eric John asked a question
okay if you recall looking kids right
remember I said particle train was
symmetric all right so you can actually
do this whichever way you like however
I'm trying to save myself some work
because I know in my final line I want
to have a look at the variables and
place them in descending order I can see
this is not going to have a variable
neither does this and neither does this
but here it's going to be different so
here I will show you the order and how
it will be affected
okay is there another question yeah like
one for six for one and all that kind of
thing I will show you you this guy will
do Pascal's triangle for you okay we're
not quite up to that step yet for now
Pascal's triangle is the most efficient
way that I will show you how this does
okay so patients are power alright
that's the first term and no it's a bit
of a mouthful and these two terms
contribute nothing but they're important
so I can set off the pattern there are
three parts to every one of the terms
are done with the first one now I do the
next one
what was the binomial coefficient next
I'm only on the second term so it's just
poor so for this now here's the
advantage of me writing this in a long
form once I've got this set up it's very
easy to write the next one I just follow
the pattern this thing is going to
decrease in power so I'm gonna get only
three of you but the other guy this guy
he increases in power so I'm gonna get
one
do you notice by the way look at the
powers your toes do you see 4 plus 0 is
4 3 plus 1 is 4
you're gonna get for every single time
once the next binomial coefficient 6 ok
you getting the hang of it now
these power decreases this power
increase
and then you go to the next term by name
of coefficient 1 4 6 for this power
decreases this power increases and
finally at my last turn
146 for one this power has decreased to
be nothing and then this time has
increased so that if you wanted to you
can see this is where I could have
started if I want it and done the whole
thing in Reverse okay do you see the way
I did it just because this one's a bit
trickier let's actually go ahead and do
this 3 to the 4 is 3 times 3 times 3 is
27 times 4 is okay okay then fix more
108 and then you multiply again which is
2 and in 16 how many Y's do I have I've
written it in descending order so 3
squared is 9
2 squared is 4 that's 36 6 lots of 36 I
think is 260 relax if you do maths as
much as I did then you would know that -
is that right don't you right there yep
next one 3 times 8 is 24 times 4 is 96
last one is just the 2 to 4 isn't it
just the tuna for
so just double check make sure you
haven't missed any turns you can see
I've got my powers four three two one
zero
that checks out why don't the times what
why do I fit multiply these through well
if you like you can just do this
manually if you want like the way we did
this one the way we did this you can do
that manually if you like or you can do
it this way the binomial theorem is that
you can do it this way and get to those
numbers straightaway using Pascal's
triangle without having to go through
the legwork oh oh my goodness do you
really want to do two plus three Y times
two plus three Y times too much do you
really really I mean you can but you end
up with this okay now remember on the
first line the first example I pointed
out what are the questions you get asked
later on is what's the greatest
coefficient last time was 240 what's the
greatest coefficient here it's jr. 16
and it happens twice which is a little
bit weird this happens sometimes you
shouldn't be that surprised because if
you look back at regular old Pascal's
triangle every second row have a look at
the terms right in the middle if you
notice every second row you've got
freeze twice then you get tens twice
then you get plenty fires twice it's
because there's an even number of terms
in that row of Pascal's triangle so
sometimes you'll get a double up